for many tourists London isn't only a
place to go sightseeing it's considered
the main city for fashion hunting
worldwide and it's crowded with shops
people spend more money on the latest
fashions here than just about anywhere
else ignant of him the English women
used to be either extremely thin or
extremely fat always kind of extreme
there was this famous writer who only
wore pink they always had to have some
kind of quirk in their clothing or
appearance mitts annaclaire UNK mitts
I'm Alfred Adrian heart is a typical
Londoner the 31 year old runs the neon
dance company and is going to show us
what londoners are wearing these days
it's like a summer look it's got a
fifties edge but it's it's still modern
so it's so I mean this dress is just
french connection but I I bought this
belt to change up a bit longer side
London's always been a treasure trove
for all sorts of things kind of what
this looks like a super Oxford Street is
London's main shopping district this is
where you'll come across a London style
with different twists
I'm gonna shows Rachel what a beautiful
girl so pretty might be it always a bit
of punk but ya Punk permits every sort
of decoration are for the gods it was
highly decorative and that's why the
industry picked up on it so quickly
cortiva Angela god-given it's been used
as a reference ever since with different
variations mi vida and I Andorian cityut
thought Adrian heart goes fashion
hunting and East London's shortage
district away from the main shopping
streets this is where she unearths new
designers she's always on the lookout
for classic style with a modern edge
Watson amor de black is like a primary
color in fashion but it always looks
significant always have on God always
slightly gothic mysterious and
intellectual serious and everything
works well in black rods from three and
four others the dancer and choreographer
lives in a former factory in London's
East End or financial district and
bohemian worlds meet her flat gives
adrian enough space for both her
creative lifestyle and her extensive
wardrobe
it's a medley of different styles and
fashions in a way but it I'm really into
to clean lines and and highlighting the
silhouette and the way so so like um
where's with this one I I really like
the line of it it's kind of almost
reminds me of Art Deco no way and of
course a London edge is also a must when
meeting up with potential sponsors ovd
cuts I can't clap at the front typically
London if you're wearing something a
little bit different and it does mean we
stand out in the crowd and a little bit
quirky but it's a play on a classic item
I'm in the white shirt so so simple in a
way that's also typical London the
blouse looks quite cheap live in
westwood also adore cheap materials she
always thought it was quite cool if the
fabric wasn't very expensive then I'm
stuff Nick their football a skirt or
globby I think it's part of good style
to successfully avoid certain trends
Zeke like to resist certain temptations
going to be left in or hand for sure to
make do with what you have in a
confident casual and cheerful manner duh
knocks over hen less frequent hi Tom's
again
Adrian's motto dress to impress also
goes for evening wear this dress is
actually a talk take away the tights and
were in dangerous territory less is more
as long as you stand out another
typically London style quirk
you